bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au mwc
sur le stand hall est comme pour parler
du lit fille avec une ville rêvée lien
elle nous présente un petit peu nous
expliquer ce qu'est le wifi ou qu'est ce
qu'on peut en faire et c'est quelque
chose qui va développer qui est très
intéressant et que pour l'instant je
suis largué là dessus
voilà très clairement nos valeurs en
fait c'est très simple nous l'olivier on
a deux technologies vous avez la
première technologie qui s'avale du
géologie et la deuxième technologie qui
s'appelle unifie nef qui est vraiment de
l'internet par la lumière donc dans le
premier cas duzac en fait vous allez
avoir les lampes qui vont
qui est très très vite et envoyer une
adresse donc un message l'utiliser pour
son application sur le smartphone tout à
fait en fait vous avez une application
qui va venir
l'information de la lumière sous
m'adresse récupérer dans le cloud est en
fait vous allez pouvoir récupérer une
photo
[Musique]
une vidéo donc ça veut dire que la
lumière
or voient une information numérique
comme n'importe quel câble ethernet
comme du wifi enfin avant tout à une
information en fait la lumière va donner
son nom d'accord non on va permettre de
récupérer l'information qui est dans le
cloud et l'envoyer sur la vocation
donc ton téléphone est connecté à
internet ou pas à regarder à internet
il récupère l'adresse de la lumière ou
l'application via internet six états à
cela correspond à un contenu est
aujourd'hui d'afficher par rapport
interne trouve cela tout à fait ça va
être utilisé dans les musées dans les
airs par un petit peu parce que
j'adorais compris premiers mois s'avère
découlent pourquoi ces premiers cas
d'usagé deuxième cas du jeune fait de
l'internet paraît lumière passé par
derrière ou alors là bas donc la
deuxième cas on a une lampe en or die
une véritable des choses la langue est
connecté à vox interne pour simplement
avec un cas grec
la langue va nous transmettent de la
lumière de la luminothérapie parce que
vous utilisez encore une fois de la led
et aussi de l'infirmer d'accord
comment ça marche de les revoir à
l'inspecteur ainsi qu'un récepteur ces
récepteurs c'est un petit dongle que tu
connecte en usb
la bêtise exactement on est brute dont
vous connecter à votre ordinateur
[Musique]
yes
la turbie directement en usb
il va capter la lumière donc l'aï
s'initialise vous allez voir ça va
coûter
et là vous êtes connexion internet wifi
si tu vois que on n'est pas du tout
connecté au réseau wifi lol y'a pas une
fille à rien du tout on va sur internet
je pense qu'on peut aller
sur youtube elle est
et vous allez avoir
une vidéo plus bas
fait rapidement
voilà j'ai là vous êtes connecté avec la
lumière d'accord donc là la techno c'est
la lumière qui peint la lampe est
connecté à internet en ethernet et un
câble et via la lumière il ya un signal
qui permet aux vrais une connexion
internet qui réceptionnait ici voilà et
on sent la batterie mais aussi ça va
être l'internet une communication dans
les deux sens d'accord qui descendent et
qui remonte votre origin est elle aussi
très basique à ce que je veux dire
comment ça marche comment la lumière
n'arrive qu'aux seniors
alors encore une fois on a quatre
sentiers la lumière l'information
d'internet c'est une suite de 0 et de 1
et on utilise un petit peu comme comme
du morceau petit comme du morceau petit
donc ça veut dire que le même signal que
je reçois dans un câble ethernet à cela
par la lumière par la lumière tout à
fait le ça veut dire par contre que je
vais rester dans la zone de rayonnement
lumineux exactement ce qui est un
inconvénient mais qui peut aussi être un
avantage parce que personne ne peut vous
prendre votre élection
d'accord là ça veut dire que j'ai pas
comme distance à peu près là à peu près
sept langues vous êtes sûre du 90 degrés
ou savent à peu près toute la table
toute la table ouais on peut imaginer le
mettre dans des grands plafonné dans des
grandes salles pour avoir un rayonnement
sur tout à fait déjà le cas en famille
il travaille avec des partenaires flickr
agissements
mettre nos solutions dans le préfet
ça veut dire que les jeunes eux mêmes
par exemple chez moi internet dans une
seule pièce en les filles je peux
beaucoup mais si vous voulez c'est
possible pas aujourd'hui le frappe au
grand public alors c'est possible mais
ça va coûter un petit peu cher pour le
grand public
si vous mettez
ça dans le plafonnier qui peut tirer des
câbles donc au niveau de l'installation
s'est encore compliquée aujourd'hui pour
les placiers ça qu'on arrivait avec
cette langue qui s'appelle magnifique
3 facile d'installation l'année
prochaine il y aura aussi une version en
luminaires
et aussi on applique pluralisme est âpre
au conflit semble de tirer des câbles
internet se sont alors fait l'entourent
les acteurs à 699 euros pour que pour
des pré commandes et en juillet pour il
y aura la première production qui a déjà
commencé à sur l'a8 180,6 pour ça qu'on
a travaillé avec 1
une heure pierre verley repères de cet
objet un bel objet connecté est capable
de diffuser une très belle
est ce qu'on peut imaginer parce que
même si effectivement ça j'imagine très
bien est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'après
tout
généraliser démocratisé avec des tarifs
qui vont baisser et une techno on a
retrouvé ce n'est pas partout dans
beaucoup d'endroits c'est quoi
l'évolution du lycée pour l'évolution
pour preuve les hommes en tout cas nous
on voit vraiment le besoin arriver c'est
à dire que les ondes radios commençaient
à être saturé donc l'unifi se pose
vraiment comme une connectivité
associées donc voilà c'est vraiment une
option et comment vous avez plus d'une
radio utilisée par exemple par le wifi
ou akadjé vous pouvez utiliser du livre
donc quand le besoin sera
nous évident aujourd'hui évidemment
l'électronique aura des prix qui ont
baissé parce qu'il y aura plus de demain
nous on travaille vraiment dans ce sens
la primature is et la technologie et
permet vous votre société aux hits comme
woods est une société française c'est
quoi l'histoire de la boîte pour les
travaillistes ont une fiche rien 2002
alors l'historique de la boîte nous
notre président qui s'appelle sua topçu
et le courant vendeur de la
technologique donc il a commencé à faire
son doctorat dans son piège dit dans la
communication de véhicule à véhicule en
2000 et en 2005
on lui a demandé de vraiment plus
recherchés cette technologie n'a donc
voilà
commune et il est à 56,9 de l'université
de versailles en 50 ans c'est quoi le la
direction à l'avenir c'est quoi le ce
que j'imagine que là aujourd'hui vous
avez produit sont déjà aboutis donc
l'avenir ce sont des années de travail
c'est quoi il ya forcément de une idée
derrière tout ça vous cautionnez son
imagination avec qui vous allez
travailler c'est quoi le vide et après
le camp stratégique
sans rentrer dans les choses qu'on peut
pas dire mais pour qu'on reprenne un
petit peu alors nous on est très
transparents ont peu à peu près pu dire
il ya ce dongle qui doit se miniaturiser
pouvoir rentrer dans les équipements
nous on se connecte la façon dont on
travaille c'est comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure on travaille avec des
partenaires éclairagiste ont justement
que eux intègrent la technologie wi fi
par howlett comme et que l'utilisateur
n'est même plus
l'impression de passer par l'audi fille
en 7 7 viendra comme le wifi aujourd'hui
quelque chose de complètement évident ça
veut dire que le
bénédicte un ordinateur ou un smartphone
à venir soit complètement intelligent et
gère la connectivité aux réseaux du wifi
du lit fier de la catch et 5 g il avait
en fait l'idée de la 5g c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on fait partie du consortium 5g et
que votre téléphone ou votre ordinateur
au moment du besoin de connexion
choisira le réseau le plus fort à ce
moment là c'est dire le wifi la 3g la 4g
das alger où la ligue de hockey junior
non merci beaucoup dans l'industrie mais
le litchi par internet
jma dit tout à l'heure qu'on ne pouvait
pas l'avoir directement sur son
smartphone
il y avait une coque tout à fait stable
rozon bully sur votre téléphone vous
n'avez pas le récepteur que vous allez
trouver ici voilà parce que c'est
toujours un petit peu trop bon douchez
oled comme on a on a créé une coque qui
servira de dongle donc aujourd'hui cette
cote existent pour nos solutions
antérieures et on est en train de
l'adapter pour la solution vous voyez
des vallières
génial l'ancienne grille merci m je vous
invite me laisser des commentaires est
ce que vous connaissez déjà
cette solution il faut savoir que c'est
un de nos abonnés qui m'a qui m'a dit
vas y vas rencontrer au mwc
quand est ce que j'ai fait quelques
petites pattes merci beaucoup merci donc
dit pas si vous connaissez est ce que
vous ça pourrait vous intéresser est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous pensez du lift
technologie mark et moi tout ça en
commentaire comme d'habitude vous invite
à laisser des jolies pousse à vous
abonner on reste connectés parce que
plein de super cool qui vont arriver et
et au mwc lui arrive et croyez moi qui
ai vu plein de choses complètement
dingue merci beaucoup à très bientôt ça
veut dire demain
[Musique]